3les
quand aura 20 ans tous les hommes seront
frais donc prochain ce sera ton égal
doha des gants blancs et un grand
handicap terre car tu seras caporal
général à cheval et sur rodez en effet
laura d'égalité un beau chapeau pointu
qui m'a fichu que c'est d'effrayer le
chat botté
au lieu de faire ça risette qui m'a
fichu des baby qui font fuir jumbo et
bambins et les petites marionnettes
pendant 30 ans et danse après 3
pirouette
quand on a 20 ans il y aura une jolie
dame dont tu seras prince charmant dans
à 32 dents et quand il ira sésame ses
bras s'ouvriront tout grand bond pour
six mois pour un temps plein en secret
des demoiselles comme polichinelle et
des fera du jour en voilà en veux tu
tues
la vie en fin de compte ce sera un
compte et la paix fait lentement
lentement se demande quand aura 20 ans
les sommes seront intelligents en
attrapant la lune dans 20 en août aura
20 ans dort à 20 en voiture
et moi j'aurai vingt ans depuis et moi
j'aurais
depuis son investiture